let's do a little bit of working and
then we'll find out whether we're on the
right track or not I negative 2 for
starters who agrees yep got a few hands
up whatever their hands down do we just
confirm what's the line that would
proceed this what comes before this
negative 2 yes right so change a true 1
and v 2 minus 3 ok so I'm going to take
this and by the way we have a fancy word
for this when you take the letters the
pretty rules and you swap back you
replace them with the numbers what's
that called yeah substitution very good
substitutions just a fancy word
literally means swap or replace or
switch right so I'm going to pop these
numbers back into their slots at exactly
like fake set the a is 1 and you're
adding now you through that so this is
calling you back to integers right so
that does equal negative 2 so I would
have written that they're lovely ok
again what light of working we're going
to put in for Part B what are you do
before you get to this answer yes
tradition like icky tell me what to you
tell me what's right yeah yep so you can
see by the way this step here maybe some
of you could do it in your head that's
lovely but I always like to write this
step down because then I'm not like not
just get it wrong just cuz i read the
question wrong or something like that
I've got all the right pieces okay
what's half of negative 3 half of the
year three yeah negative 1 i'm gonna
write it as negative one and a half i
made 1.5 is the same which seems these
in the same idea but i started with
fractions so i'm going to try and stay
in factual and if i can and then i take
away one is that does that look okay
yeah okay now this is a bit interesting
have a look carefully at this line right
negative one half and then you take away
one again is that me I doing this yeah
yeah yeah very good in fact if you have
an answer like this and maybe there you
got the sensor which is fine I love all
of you too Nikhil was talking about the
on the number line just down now if you
put if I put one really one and negative
two over here negative what a half is
where I'm starting yeah so it's like
halfway in between those and then this
minus one tells me which direction to go
in right or left go to the left yeah so
I'm going to go that way negative 1
which means i'm even more negative than
I was before sometimes I think the
answer is negative chew huff okay I'm
negative half by the way or a half
rather that's not a crazy on top can you
see where a half control like it's a
very easy to mistake to make where does
it come from what's happened a couple of
things right here no even one okay for
starters you like the one half take away
one that is a half right and also you
might be our this true leg is there two
negatives make a positive 2 years do
make a positive sometimes when do two
negatives make a positive so what else
doesn't saving you yeah next thing
everyone is like free taking negative
two so something like that said this
when you see them next to each other
like that now by the way there's
actually an operation hiding in there
what's the operation how do you when you
don't see what we do yeah it's times so
do you remember we did that table right
when we saw negative numbers times they
do numbers they do give you positive
numbers right when you're adding and
subtracting it's different when moving
was shuffling up and down or left and
right on the number line okay etihad
subtracting a negative number then
that's a positive yes very good and the
reason why I do I have one on the board
I don't so if I had something like one
takeaway negative 3 right remember what
this is like think back to op do you
remember what this is like these
negatives are like weights that are
holding you down and you're taking away
so wait so where does the house go when
he pushes all that furniture remember it
goes up right so that's why the result
is going to be
you got higher than before ok this one
here so this is that that's a big pair
of brackets 0 if you see just those
brackets together then it's like i'll
multiply who's this yeah it does you're
right i could have known a big table ok
so negative two and a half glad we
cleared that up is this one also
negative two and a half should we find
out which we give this a go I'm going to
do that what did crew call it again
what's a core studying this that I'm
going to do the substitution step ok so
let's give this a go to be what's be
again negative 3 song is going to run
that 2 times negative 3 minus C minus
uh-huh yep that's what's on the top
there and then i'm going to divide by 3
ok two times negative 3 i'm going to
shoot one step at a time three times i
get through it yeah they're 6 i've got a
minus haha there and i haven't done
anything with this what's that thing on
the bottom chord get start of the day
just as well it's all very similar to a
divisor it's that it's the denominator
in a fraction accord that do nothing ok
but what can i what can i do on the top
here on the numerator minus six minus R
ha yeah oh whoa hold on a second very
close but this is the same thing we were
looking at here right I'm going to start
at negative 6 which is like way over
here and then I'm going to go which way
to the left I'm going to get even more
negative our time so it's negative six
and a half and that's divided by 3 i'm
running out of space a little bit here
um but when I have a look and I say
equals can I do with this that can help
me this question is a lot trickier than
I thought yeah ok that's good I'm I know
you guys shouldn't do this and keep
going but I've run out of space so what
can I do here i'm still not finished yet
life any takers yea nay okay so you're
going straight to an answer I'm not sure
if I'm convinced that is the answer yet
let's try and work out what's going on
here this isn't it hard to work with I
don't think any of us including me I
won't care to think ago obviously right
so I want to remember we can change the
form of our numbers to make it a little
easier to work yes instead of yeah I
gotta go to a decimal or I could go to a
mix of my mix near already I can go to a
percentage as well as future which I
think would be the easiest when you've
got a fraction in the top numbers bigger
than the bottom to remember that's gone
yeah an improper fraction now watch why
this is useful how do i write this as an
improper fraction can we convert it um
yeah let's go ahead there's a minus sign
as well so Marty yeah 13 / 2 and i'm
dividing by 3 ok we're almost there one
doing this yeah ok so yeah I can think
about that yeah and when you divide
fractions what you do yes ok oops 1013
so if I turn this into a reciprocal
that's gone upside down what does that
do do because that's not these are not
the same Val bar where am I going to go
ahead yeah does he ok and I'm pretty
much there now I've only got one more
thing to do I'm just going to multiply
straight across right so negative 13
times what is and two times three years
ok now that question was surprisingly
difficult we really had to go through a
few spinning turns to get there right
but i'm pretty happy to the way that we
went through it can we just rewind for a
second what were the things that we did
was this first step can you tell me what
we do it has
the buck so what else Sonia room yeah
substitution so that's the first thing
you do what did i do from them really
what did i do all the way in here what
were these two lines about what did I do
yeah okay I did simplify right i'm going
to call this step 2 but the important
thing is i just watched this numerator I
didn't worry about the denominator yeah
didn't confuse myself by doing too many
things at once okay and then the last
thing I did this is step three is I had
to work out what to do with this divided
by three and it was a little bit icky
but we got there eventually okay do you
want me to do the last question or are
you happy with it do I didn't do it
hands up who dug into it on the board
ends up ok let's see all right let's do
it so by the way um just have a look
before we do this last one I count one
two three four five six seven lines of
working when I had a look and I walked
around I don't think I saw anyone with
even maybe three or four maybe a drink a
lot of things in your head don't do that
I want to see the way you've actually
purchased a question yes oh I'm get like
three okay like I said I want to see I
mean maybe if you did a few live less
that's okay but if you have like no
lines of working that's kind of a big
problem because I need to show you I
need to see you show me the way you were
thinking okay